[Aplausos]
tava quais a tentada continuava
conversas sobre os cinemas a cinema por
também tem uma história em lisboa no
cinema de indianos que tinha 13 anos foi
com os amigos tentar ver um filme
pornográfico e como as chaves não
iríamos entrar naturalmente então
fizemos acho que evoluímos uns dos
outros como a gabardine e conseguimos
ver o filme não era a garganta funda mas
pronto é hora para isso vai ser o mais
próximo que eu estarei num discurso do
prêmio nobel
quando escrevo contesto a justificar
este convite e agradeço e como a palavra
destas dos pais não é verão na altura
pra dar um título e o título o respeito
é muito bonito parece que é isso
ora é a respeito do suspeito ó dos
muitos e variados tipos e formas de
praticar sim jima uma breve a
autobiografia prematura porque só tem
quais 40 e 60 anos né e parece que isso
é muito pouco na vida humana e mais
ainda no universo
no entanto numa vida humano já qualquer
coisa é o suficiente para perceber que o
mais perto do respeito por um sanduíche
de mais tarde por uma criança filho
único trave indo os avós os dois avós
paternos e avó materna foi a pessoa mais
por exemplo nesse ferdinand
o maior exemplo do respeito por uma nova
vida na família de wu em particular a
minha avó fixadas já desaparecida como
todos os meus avós dele querem um
conjunto cartas escritas num período
difícil e publicadas no livro kova deixa
usar numa altura em que estava na
holanda estava longe e minha avó
morria e sem que eu pudesse acontecer
viva voz o seu exemplo maior era na sua
vida durante séu brigada com possíveis
valim que pensava quando escrevia e
sempre que volto quando as provações mil
ao romã ea fosse resistir
é nela que peso foi a minha primeira
professora avançadas
o meu lugar de paz e sabedoria para uma
mulher religiosa e até posso dizer vi
ata
mas isso não evitou dava o riso ea
tolerância para com as minhas escolhas
de budista de inverno e no distrito de
verão avançadas era capaz de chamar
trampolineiros aos mentirosos os
políticos sobretudo nós nunca sem
incluir izawa nunca perdeu o controlo ea
dignidade isto são formas de respeito
transversais e universais nada tem que
ver com dogmas religião ou ideologias
são leis problemas da vida infelizmente
aprendi muito cedo com a minha avançadas
para as palavras foram e cry venceram a
minha forma de vida
acho que no fundo de uma frase pode
estar toda a essência de um indivíduo
não posso dizer que devo respeitar todos
os partidos mas isso não é todo
relevante ninguém tem nem morto
uma coisa é escrever pode ser uma arma
op então uma pena inspiradora pode ser
uma arma poderosa e vingança até as
folhas um instinto do escritor como já
foi o meu é verdade de cimento até pode
estar lá nas pernas a hipótese de
evolução sabem estar aqui é sinal de
respeito
bom no trabalho por mim tal como ser
lido premiado anunciado
no entanto o maior respeito penso eu só
chega quando depois de ler o que montou
o que está aqui escrito até poder
acreditar que foi uma obra muito maior
do que o autor talvez do divino é o meu
lado de budista de inverno a falar
enquanto escritor o meu único mas
publicado está lhe chama essas caras
tambo conta de forma livre e ficcionada
a partir de fatos reais as várias
bíblias
da família e se for dita kamundo isso é
uma história que o que eu descobri
quando era guia da agência na amada
o porto era guia de viagens e foi
naquelas casas que esta história
apareceu o encontro
ora ao escrever com este livro a
história desta família para coisas como
a fortuna não pode comprar o suspeito
era um argumento ricos eram os hot seu
do oriente mas não foi isso que deu o
respeito porque eram judeus
logo foram perseguidos e exterminados ou
seja o pai nosso compra conquistas e nem
assim temos a segurança de que será
conquistado
talvez por isso acima do poder do
dinheiro nesta família estivesse a
filantropia anônima como o modo de vida
o serviço
a obediência forças muito mais poderosas
das causas que podem o homem inclui um
partido um país a mesma religião faz
parte do percurso inacabada da sabedoria
é que faz de um homem sábio porque sabe
que falar tanto quanto saiba usar os
camundongos ensinaram mais do que
qualquer família de sangue
exceto avançadas e penso que o respeito
intelectual pode virar para o suporte
físico e curiosamente muitos os artistas
escritores fazendo da sua arte uma
espécie de um combate em da vida um
ringue estar aqui neste fórum paulo um
ringue e aí adversários não discordo
porque porque acho que há uma dualidade
entre o motorista é preciso nossas o
irmão desse filme eo justiça de palavras
que o escritório pode ser que no fundo
as palavras como punhos no entanto
também pode usar o contrário é que o
respeito mil
quem consegue superá las por outras vias
mais compassivos né
e escrevi uma última frase dizendo que
estou estar aí
entre estes dois mundos respeitando as
minhas naturezas
fiz uma aula conta ainda tenho uns
minutinhos não lê em voz alta é algumas
pessoas aqui que eu conheço não viaja é
minha página hora do tempo livre do
piloto então o motorista acidental é
daqui que atinge a maioria não mais a
nossa isso ai pensei 'não não não é
[Música]
e tem uma relação fortíssima com o norte
porque estava orçado era do braga dos
céus e não eu não acho que ele atua e e
brincar com essa história do nobel
professora maio quando ganhou o nobel é
o nosso único nova na verdade é única em
língua portuguesa
fui eu sou o vovô como inspiração
penso que muitas pessoas tratam os avós
e os pais aspirações ou seja o respeito
é de facto uma aprendizagem mais do que
todo o ano e é na família que cria e
desenvolve um eventual aumento produto e
até o fim e sua vez fomos fazendo
exatamente o mesmo com os filhos
alguém perguntava como é que eu era
capaz de educar filhos estou sempre a
viajar e se elas não vão comigo na hora
de educar filhos não é só estar por
exemplo deve estar presente no canadá
não é provavelmente o maior exemplo
disputar até agora foi este que viajar é
talvez a melhor forma de descobrir nos
gestos palavras o respeito à autoridade
a melhor forma de conhecermos o outro e
nós próprios na outra e não é preciso
ser grande de viagens alguém agora as
minhas viagens com a segmentação em
lisboa a fazer para sair tutuca
é uma pergunta que também fazem esse
livro tem muitas curiosidades é um livro
de crônicas onde o ebay por exemplo a
palavra respeito na forma das
autoridades da polícia e se não tem
muito respeito por esta é cuidado pra
não dizer que não tem nenhuma e e uma
vez estava a passear umas pessoas
portuguesas perguntar o que estava ali a
fazer se eu era uma espécie de com sal
que ele frustrá lo disse
eles não não estou não estou aqui
fazendo isso é uma narrativa um
divertimento sociológica estou fazendo e
que provavelmente só como jornalista por
ter pessoas tão próximas havia lugar
ainda estivesse no confissionário como
experiência não pode ser melhor suporta
o jornalista bom viajante também a
transmitir essas pessoas não são
proteínas e quanto ainda uma outra
história também pode ter sua graça sobre
o respeito a si é um casal de holandeses
que a quem eu disse que tinha morado na
holanda tem estado a obter conselhos até
um bocado penosa mas também porque minha
mulher é uma feliz páscoa que tem muito
sucesso na holanda é cristina branco é
minha mulher e mãe da minha filha mais
nova e o casal bis e não pode ser você
está mentindo não pode ser você não é o
gorila que se levantam que como ainda
que se levantar de fazer aguiar tuk tuks
e eu dizia pois o estádio está um
preconceito ea uma falta tremenda estão
trabalho simplesmente notável e artbhz o
embaixador 11 paulo derrota um absurdo
cultura uma pessoa num apaixonado pela
história de zezé não é todo um trabalho
na e mas é parte entre o santa é essa
porque o desrespeito por ser um condutor
tubos porque nos pede por ser um técnico
de som
mission um faxineiro até disse parece
uma flecha de prata e até 11 uma das
coisas mais trágicas das relações
humanas
mas isto porque nada diz faz sozinho né
este evento estas os livros aquela
fotografia do card blossom foi mal se dá
gosto muito de ter na capa porque pensei
que tinha que pagar é buscar mundo que
eu não conheci mas também fotografias em
casa como se fossem da família ao lado
dos avós passaram a ser parte da família
o senhor meter que era o no seio destas
cada 16 em istambul mas já foram ao
bairro da lata pedra gala no cine destas
cada um restaurante que foi uma prisão
inglesa e este senhor que eu conheci
nestas casas de madrugada enquanto a
história buscar muito primeira parte a
primeira opção
até lá o seu restaurante sua casa e isso
é uma recomendação vantagens procuram
coisas onde escrevem jantar e tal pela
fox governo um bombom hack importante e
um minuto ou seja viajar a escrever o
jornalismo
primeiro à literatura
entretanto a palavra sempre temos aqui
uma palavra enorme parece que as
conferências têm tóquio não são
temáticas neto necessariamente né
mas tem que haver sempre uma palavra
escolherá muito esta muito bonito
agregado porque acho que juntar pessoas
é sempre um momento muito bonito e gosto
muito fazer em forma de cursos de
conversa sobre livros conversas o
viagens porque mesmo aí muito mais do
que um laboratório no um consultório do
psiquiatra que encontramos
a resposta pra festas grandes questões
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]